[Musique]
au monsieur excusez moi je suis vraiment
désolé mais j'ai oublié d'enquêtrice
n'ont même pas vu ce qui tresse de dons
pardon non gigue en fête pas je vais
m'en occuper maintenant
d'anti décapante j'ai pris des clichés
de paul mais ça me va aussi
dites moi vous appeler comme un mois ses
musiques fantastiques sérieusement votre
nom de famille c'est un adjectif comme
pascal gentil
oui eh bien monsieur kalt astique vous
avez un passé loïck et la caisse des
parkings c'est clair
[Musique]
et quant à trouver un taf tête des
chewing gum je peux parler d'avenir ça
allait
[Musique]
mais voilà non mais c'est quoi
laisse tomber c'est pas de ma faute
patron serait à cause de mes gros doigts
en cailloux ska tout ce qui rend vers
crois que j'ai un truc pour pas
franchement t'as vraiment l'intelligente
et mis dessus d'une blanquette j'ai
connu des huit beaucoup plus
intelligente que ça depuis quand les
cailloux par lequel les rouleaux avec
ses blogs je comprends pourquoi l'état
ne faisons pas de bouche
bonjour holloway vite peu respectée
parce que je suis pas ça on a trouvé ça
un super journal n'en voulait je suis
les coûts
[Musique]
bonjour un poulet rôti s'il est adouci
le quidam attention être une personne
aux actes
attends attends vanille pas fanny 14
[Musique]
suivi reste sa balle au je vais être
obligé de te muter quoi goûter lutter
muté c'est-à-dire était mutée quoi
couvrir madame alors g2a points et
enseignants oyonnax non sérieux c'est un
peu millions là où 80 taf ne t'en fais
pas l'homme torche
c'est seulement à céder enflammé torche
[Musique]
sécurité le niveau de la tente en tout
cas si vous mettez sécurité au niveau de
la porte surtout qu'est ce qui vous
plaît
non mais sérieux éloignez-vous l'as
dangereux merde
[Musique]
et le respect des lieux publics ça parle
et mes cheveux je vais prises dès
maintenant et attend une hta trouver un
meilleur boulot quand on parle de boulot
qu'on parle pas de l'arbre ouais
allez les gars 2 sur 5 2e mais même ces
plastiques passerelle oui en effet c'est
parti
[Musique]
ça saoule et tu saoules eh oui c'est
comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
action top
[Musique]
ces actions
c'est super action action soit les
pilotes actions athris 20 tasses et
pourtant pas de lampe torche non sur la
formation et l'emploi
je ne peux rien il a trouvé 1 4 donc la
valeur
ah ah
[Musique]